an aurora shimmers in the night
sky and for a moment a startling
seemingly alien realm becomes
illuminated this is the world of serara
and despite appearances these are not
aliens but the descendants of birds and
fish we've been following this Saga for
several videos watching as over the past
280 million years in IAL group of
finches and other creatures left on a
distant moon have evolved into a
dizzying variety of forms when we last
checked in this world had been flung
into cataclysm and the intelligent sea
stewards had been transported away to
another realm now Serena is beginning to
recover from the loss of its top species
although the greatest dangers and most
extraordinary life forms still lie ahead
so let's return to this world the birds
and remember to support Creator Dylan
beta on patreon using the links
below our journey begins with the Rising
Sun here in the northern s lands the
morning Rays illuminate a very tapestry
of Life Thorn grazers feed upon the
Soden plant matter and unleash their
bellowing calls a predatory Drake
vulture scourers for prey from above the
Towering Watchtower wos Blom over the
entire scene these species represent
some of the lineages that will come to
prominence in this new era we are now in
the hot house age and the lands of
Serena have become splintered by the
highest ever sea level though volcanism
is on the decline and the end of this
world looms ever closer an atmosphere
heavy in carbon dioxide means Sarena has
never been so warm or so conducive to
radical experimentation on the Inland
flood Plains a monstrous descendant of
the burrowing burle attempts to bring
down a smaller hog lump while a fox
Trotter watches from the branches all
three species have had to radically
change their behavior in a short period
to
survive on the ever shifting Coast
adaptability is even more essential this
tentacled Shore scer in their chicks are
just humble scavengers at present but
there's no telling what the future will
bring from the water emerges a sand lber
a kind of semi-terrestrial snail to the
shore scers it looks like
breakfast in the open sea other snail
descendants are enjoying a buffet of
their own the snaggle tooth calara have
become huge apex predators and their
preferred prey the escin are also a type
of marine snail the Seas belong to the
invertebrates now and as the eons pass
the the gastropods grip upon the Marine
ecosystem will only tighten as larger
and larger species arise in the post Ice
Age Waters some like the spike rays will
proliferate under the murky surface of
freshwater rivers in astonishingly High
numbers their body plans converging upon
that of modern race
species another Dawn comes to this Brave
New World on the northern coast of
sastra the body of a Titanic Shimmer
Shiner currently the largest Marine
snail species washes up on the Sands all
manner of carnivores quickly descend
upon this rare Feast there's no time to
take turns eventually nightfalls and a
very peculiar creature emerges to assess
what remains of the carcass it's a night
creeper another burrowing burled
descendant that's strictly nocturnal the
early bird might get the biggest portion
but the night creeper had has carved out
a niche for itself snatching up midnight
leftovers of course not everyone has to
stress about sticking to the Shadows the
omnivorous scopin descendants of the
otter likee scurck birds have arrived
upon a rather imposing body plan the
future of this lineage will be very
bright indeed more familiar dynasties
flourish in one of the last relatively
dry biomes on Sarena the Uplands here
members of the battering helmet head
Thorn Grazer species Clash over
territory close to a herd of jumpo wos a
relative of the Watchtower wos they're
far from the strangest trunked bird
species in this era in the southern
jungles for example the Speedy lump opes
race through the underbrush their facial
flanges displaying bright colors to
attract mates in the polar Basin The
Peculiar shuck lumps have turned their
trunks into a means of prying open
shellfish for an easy meal the shuck
lumps appear nonthreatening but the Lash
lip caracal an emergent carnivorous
trunk bird appear anything but and in
this case appearances aren't deceiving
the Lash lips are ruthlessly effective
Hunters the Hun House age can be
ruthless but it can also be a stage for
unexpectedly touching moments here a
mother blow blump the most rotund of the
drunk Birds has taken in a rather
confused Fox Trotter who has gained the
scent of her young after spending time
in their vicinity though its roaming
instincts will eventually cause this fox
Trotter to wander on it is nice to be
part of a family if just for a day not
long ago Sarena was a Haven for this
sort of cross species cooperation but
the most intelligent and altruistic
species have all since vanished
displaced to another world or rendered
extinct by the Calamity that capped off
the previous era though deeply tragic
this loss has left behind an intriguing
intelligence
vacuum back on the coast the shore scers
have begun to diversify with some new
offshoots becoming increasingly social
it's a development to keep an eye on as
the hot house age wears on new forest
ecosystems offer new ways of life here a
gravedigger sub species sinks its teeth
into a hapless Thorn Grazer you wouldn't
know it by glancing at the Predator but
its distant relatives the theic
gravediggers were once the most
intelligent species on Sarena elsewhere
in the forest however a different
subspecies is following more closely in
the thalassic gravedigger footsteps this
is a Spire py A Primitive tool user who
feeds on honey ants they're a reasonably
brainy bird bird although not half as
clever as their theic relatives another
species with a remarkable ancestry is
the scre honk these long- necked
herbivores are members of the giraffe
owl an emerging clay that like Earth
giraffes browse on vegetation that most
grazers simply can't reach but where did
such an unusual clay emerge from they're
actually the distant descendants of the
seraps who once reigned Supreme in
Sarena Skies one small surviving lineage
the Fallen Angels found a niche
Scavenging on the ground becoming
increasingly well adapted for
terrestrial Locomotion from this initial
giraffe Val body plan a wide variety of
unusual offshoots have emerged and over
the next several million years this
group will only become
stranger but for now the giraffe have
competition in the hot house forests
from the spiral siren horns a type of
thorn grade ER with an elaborate nasal
structure that produces Eerie musical
calls these pack animals have reached
impressive sizes converging on a niche
similar to Modern bison yet both the
siren horns and the giraffe foul need to
keep an eye on a new upstart so gobblers
are huge aggressive creatures related to
the scoins that seem poised to follow in
the Titanic footsteps of Earth sorop
pods and while the so gobblers are herb
pores the related skogar have a taste
for meat as well as veggies at 3 and 1/2
M or 12 ft tall the only thing more
formidable than their monstrous size is
their monstrous appetite a group of
skogar can strip a small island of
vegetation in just a few weeks before
crossing the water to do the same to
another land mass one might assume that
nothing could rival their destructive
power but in the southern bogs an even
more ravenous force is waiting this
trunked bird is about to fall prey to
the insatiable bog shaggoth a super
organism made up of thousands of
cooperating ants bog shaggoths are the
ultimate scavengers though slightly less
aggressive than their Ice Age ancestors
the sea shaggoths the fact that such a
deadly lineage has endured into the hot
house era could spell trouble for the
age to come it's a good time to be up in
the branches the forest canopy is now
home to not just bird descendants but
snail descendants as well the peculiar
tree gups are derived from Marine snails
that became amphibious during the start
of the hot house and are now well
adapted for a wooded
environment once the woods of Serena
were tended to by the antlers one of the
first intelligent tool users who
tragically faded from history long ago
though their allies the graved diggers
preserve their memory for a Time the
gravediggers have now also disappeared
from Sara surface but while these
antlers are long extinct one lone
relative the survivors have endured into
the middle hot house and as a changing
climate turns Marshland to Savannah the
antlers have an incredible opportunity
to
adapt we now return to the image of the
Aurora lit swamp land this scene takes
place in Sara's warm Southern Pole where
for several months the sun does not rise
and in the darkness Evolution has sired
creatures never before seen shimmering
bioluminescence a rare sight in
terrestrial organisms lights up sections
of the Polar Forest on the forest floor
a digdag another burrowing burled
descendant scres for a meal close to
this Badger siiz life form is a fan club
of smaller Flyers who are hopeful the
digdag will uncover something they can
steal but all smaller life forms need to
tread carefully for The Uncanny spook
hides in the shroud of night a member of
the batlike lineage of triats the Spooks
large ears form a dish-like structure
that allows them to hone in on the
slightest sound yet Spooks are not the
canniest hunters in The Long Dark swamp
something very special has emerged in
this Darkness a new tool user squab
goblins are relatives of the shore scers
that have put their tentacles to work
crafting rudimentary Spears this
combined with their ability to hunt in
packs have made these Tiny Terror
formidable indeed though the squab
goblins currently lack the true spark of
sapience there is enough kindling here
to one day hopefully reignite the Lost
fire of advanced intelligence and
observing the squab goblins is another
bright-eyed bird species Boggle birds
are clever omnivores who have learned to
act as watchdogs for the squab goblins
in exchange for food perhaps they too
will carry the torch of intelligence
onwards for now day is breaking at last
after many months of darkness and with
the light come the dawn Walkers large
bipedal herbivores that hibernate during
the winter only to Rew awaken when the
sun in The Greenery returns and they
aren't the only Giants who return with
the sun huge giraff owl called Crown
crested skybreakers descend upon the
forest coming home following their long
migration North for the duration of the
winter during the height of Summer the
southern swamp becomes almost
unrecognizable as biodiversity increases
one rather unassuming species The
Aquatic River Carver acts as Steward of
this
biodiversity like Earth beavers River
Carvers or ecosystem engineers damning
and Shifting the flow of fresh water to
create an optimal environment in which
to raise their young a parent must do
what they can for it's a dangerous world
out there some of the largest Birds ever
seen on Sarena now prowl the northern
continent descendants of the saw
gobblers the sosur might technically be
herbivores but they're hard strict
vegetarians these aggressive creatures
will happily supplement their diet with
small animal life should the need arise
including chicks of their own species
though this tree will keep these
hatchlings safe with the rise of sosur
survival on Serena is now far more
challenging it's a good time to have
allies the superb squab Boon are
relatives of The Long Dark squab goblins
that have learned to cooperate in packs
and craft simple tools TOs and they're
not the only crafty tentacle bird on the
Block the unusual Boomer squab booon
also operates in Clans and have learned
to build traps to catch fish although
the primary function of their strange
tentacles is to amplify their mating
call like a megaphone next to these
species the blood breasted squab Boon
doesn't seem to have much going for it
Beyond an unusual Hue yet out of all the
squab Boons they are the ones with the
grandest Destiny for now now the end of
the hot house is looming ever closer yet
before this era comes to a close a final
spectacular environment will emerge we
are now 290 million years into the
Serena experiment and though tectonic
shifts have slowed to a crawl new
mountains Rise Against the distant Sky
these sky islands are actually vast
terrestrial reefs formed from layers of
spire trees and they serve as a stage
for REM remarkable new evolutionary
dramas gliding between the cliffs is a
superb Sky serpent a type of lim scurck
these Hunters can soar for short
distances by catching air underneath
their parachute like bodies much like
the Draco lizards here on Earth other
snake-like Predators have a different
tactic for getting the drop on prey
Cliff strike Worms lurk in the crevices
of the sky islands lashing out with
their curved mandibles to ins snare
anything unlucky enough to be caught
unaware but the cags of Sky Islands
don't just hide Predators they also
conceal prey here an herbivorous star
Bara takes Shelter From The Long
posterior limb of a sky heel a bite from
the Star Bar's beak might be enough to
dissuade the sky heel from digging
deeper into its domain although in The
Game of Life these two species are well
matched the sky islands are just one of
the many new field fields of competition
in the late hot house in the Arctic a
northern equivalent to The Long Dark
swamp has emerged in the form of the
night Forest this massive vertical
ecosystem is home to trees so tall that
the branches feel like an entirely
separate World from the forest floor
over 100 m or 350 ft off the ground a
red rasp rests in the branches though
their hooked tongue appears fearsome the
rasp primar feeds on insect larvae that
they dig from the bark of trees a world
away on the forest floor the baffling
pris muffalo also enjoys the occasional
insect snack a descendant of the
battering helmet heads prismal sport
highly unusual headrests both to impress
mates and scare off Rivals at the very
edge of the night Forest a tiny equin
likee relative of the Prisma falope The
Equinox is about to be prayed upon by
the ruff rasp a relative of the red rasp
it's a tricky task for such a small
Predator but these unusual times call
for risky
behavior for the late hot house is an
era of uncertainty in the oceans life is
increasingly pushed to the coast as the
global climate reeks havoc on deep water
environments the result is a shallow
water ecosystem of extreme competition
and extreme life forms one of the most
usual are the wandering wellin new
arrivals on the Aquatic scene that
despite appearances are actually the
descendants of tentacled Shore scers
that took to the Sea like Earth whales
wellkin have evolved to filter feed and
have radiated out into a number of
unusual forms including the striker
wellin whose outer two tentacles have
elongated into highly effective fish
catchers yet as Predators the wellin
pale in comparison to the Colossal kiaan
the single largest Hunters ever to exist
on Serena exceeding 52 ft or 16 m in
length and weighing up to 40 tons these
Giants are amazingly yet another
descendant of marine slugs though the
end of this world creeps ever closer
Serena has entered an age of giants
where predator and prey Clash like never
before in the southern pole a giant Dawn
Walker tries to frighten off a Sleek
fangu fangu Wars are capable Hunters but
this one isn't fully grown yet and might
be in over its head given the size of
its Quarry In The Sky Islands a far
smaller drama unfolds between a painted
Jackalope and a long toothed goat sucker
neither species weighs more than 2 kg or
4 lb but their will to survive is no
less Fierce than the largest of Serena's
animals and speaking of of on the
Northern continent certain sosur are now
among the largest animals ever to walk
on Serena but with exceptional prey
comes exceptional predators subjugators
are a relatively new Guild of megapol
bipedal tribs large enough to pose a
threat to juvenile sosur skirmishes
between these two groups are often awe
inspiring a Clash of Titans not seen
since the Mesozoic of Earth relatives of
the sosur
the Regal scosi also seem like something
out of the age of dinosaurs these huge
scurck might appear too large to be
under threat of predation but the late
hot house is a time of Monsters the
imperious River dragon is a leviathan
large enough to drag scosi into the
murky depths when pondering such a beast
it's easy to think of nature as a
constant escalation of violence but
nature has a silly side as well
Elsewhere on the Northern continent
Bower buuck are a type of giraff fow
that work hard to construct colorful
towers of vegetation to impress
potential mates this sort of behavior
can attract Predators as well but such
are the Perils of love some love stories
are wholly unique here a male flutter
Fox is trying to court a large female
Moon Beast these two species aren't
closely related but the flutter Fox
doesn't seem deterred it's a small
reminder that the engine of nature will
create sights one might never
expect wandering spider weeds are a type
of carnivorous plant that have learned
to move through a cycle of continuous
Leaf replacement they aren't
particularly quick only able to move
around 2 m or 6 ft per year but they're
an intriguing species that is quietly
evolved in the background of Serena and
on the subject of species that have
evolved in the background ant leers have
now Diversified into numerous successful
forms bulldozers are large omnivores
with antlers powerful enough to stun
predators and mating rifal other
bulldozers have evolved hooked antlers
designed for quick slashes though none
of these ant leers have continued to
carry the torch of intelligence their
woodcrafter cousins once bore they are
nonetheless capable life forms in their
own right considering Sara's current
biodiversity it is difficult to imagine
that the end is near the northern polar
Basin for example has never been as rich
with life as it is 290 million years
post establishment but there are warning
signs on the horizon that cannot be
ignored as volcanism continues to
decline Serena's magnetic field weakens
and with it the atmosphere has started
to thin allowing for increased harmful
radiation to reach the planet surface
the Final Chapter has come at last as a
mass extinction Looms on the surface it
is time we briefly turn our attention to
a hidden world below for underneath the
exterior of Serena is a network of
Chambers home to long-forgotten lineages
that have had eons to adapt to the dark
very little of the life Within These
Caverns is currently known but as the
surface declines an underground world
might rise back on the surface a group
group of squab goblins and Bogle Birds
watch the Setting Sun a cold snap has
frozen the marsh solid and though this
dip in temperature will not last it is a
sign of more permanent changes to come
will Sara's burgeoning intelligent life
be able to adapt in
time jumping forward a brief 5 million
years beyond the end of the hot house
age a family of flutter foxes watch a
forest fire engulf their environment
rain no longer extinguishes these brush
fires as the atmosphere continues to
weaken the end is very close indeed but
here in sera's Twilight hours sapience
has returned at last the blood breasted
squab Boon of Ages past has given rise
to the silven spark a highly social
species that is beginning to craft
complex tools and they're not the only
tool using tentacle bird they share this
world with the slaughter sprinters
descendants of squab goblins who have
taken to the ples following the collaps
of The Long Dark swamp ecosystem and
their Boggle bird allies have achieved
advanced intelligence as well becoming
the artistically inclined whisper Wings
all three species have Arisen in close
proximity to each other and their
Futures shall be deeply
intertwined but is it too little too
late with the age of giants coming to a
crashing close and global temperatures
dropping it is unclear what hope these
new soft fonts have Sarena has always
been a story of Hope and tragedy of joy
and sorrow whatever the future holds
life is always full of
surprises the final chapter of the end
ultimac scine is still to come but
that's all I can give away for now if
you enjoyed this series as much as I do
once again there are links to Dylan
beta's patreon and the patreon of guest
artist troll man in the
description and by the way as always
thank you for watching if you enjoyed
this video and want to support the
channel consider liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next
video